but if the press were actually doing its
job
you'd be hearing a lot about the
bloomberg new economy forum which has
been going on
all week attended by modern day global
leaders and wealthy elites who supported
joe biden
and they're so confident in their agenda
so buoyed by
what they see as the defeat of the
america first movement
that they aren't even trying to hide
their disdain any longer
for american sovereignty were you
surprised by how
how badly america is done on that very
quickly
it's mind-blowing when the paris
agreement came into force the united
states withdrew
from it and left us and all the other
countries
around the world is disappointed the
marketplace is encouraged by
having a leader now that is more
inclusive
inclusive of course if they have their
way
you're going to have no say in the
future of the global economy no way to
affect it no ability to change it
it's up to american patriots to oppose
what they're trying to do
at almost every turn and that means
supporting senators kelly luffler
and david perdue in georgia that runoff
on january
5th and it means keeping pressure on
republican elected officials across the
board
let's face it before trump a lot of them
were wrong
on both trade and immigration got to
keep an eye on them
and over the next four years these
republicans are going to come
under enormous media and financial
pressure
to appease the global elites and make no
mistake about it the globalists are
determined to ram
through their agenda and given biden's
age and mental acuity or lack thereof
they probably feel like
they have a very narrow window very
short window to achieve their grand
designs
if biden gets into office get ready for
the fight of your life
over the next years at every turn they
will try to subvert your rights
and take your prosperity to start
they're going to crater your personal
finances
with insane climate policies we need a
whole economy transition backing those
who are part of the solution and taking
capital away from those who are part of
the problem
a cap and trade mechanism or some kind
of carbon tax
an active carbon market with a carbon
price
that would continue to step up
in level every year guaranteed tax
increases on energy
would devastate the middle class but
they know that the elites know that
that's their entire point
remember now we made an appeal to aoc
to work with us to stop some of these
types of
crushing globalist deals but bloomberg
and his pals are really smart
they know exactly the kind of rhetoric
that's needed to win people like
alexandria ocasio-cortez over
climate change is going to kill us all
if we're waiting for things to be
delivered in 2050
we're not going to be around to see them
well we don't have a lot of time at
somewhere between 10 and
20 years we need to invest now we don't
have 10 or 12 years to build new power
stations we need them
in 18 months on trade which we
highlighted earlier this week bloomberg
and his globalist cronies made clear in
a special report
what their overriding goal is sticking
together by guarding
against the risk of the us and china
decoupling oh they don't want that
bloomberg and lots of other american
plutocrats have billions tied up in
china
so decoupling from the communist regime
would be a disaster for them personally
even though it would be a huge boon to
american industries
and american workers now on covid
billionaires like bill gates could
barely hide their excitement for what a
biden presidency might bring
people come into the country do they
have a digital certificate that says
whether they've been vaccinated or not
as the u.s rejoins the who this idea of
what is the vaccine certificate look
like hopefully that dialogue
uh will will begin show me your papers
now don't for a second think that you're
going to have a seat at that table
for this dialogue you're just supposed
to sit down
and do what you're told remember well
that's what dr fauci told us anyway
coincidentally the chinese cdc's chief
epidemiologist had basically the same
message yesterday
in the eastern culture we have
a community venue uh is higher than the
individual
venue in the united states and european
countries
the personal uh right is the top
priority the most important is everybody
takes the order and follow the
instruction
everyone take the order and follow the
instruction or else do what you're told
mask up open your wallet distance
get the vaccine certificate give up your
freedom your autonomy
and do not under any circumstances ask
any real questions
does that sound like a fun world to live
in well this is the type of mentality
that will guide
the biden administration's coveted
response and of course good old joel
will bend over backwards to appease the
world health organization
a prospect that has emboldened world
health organization head dr
tedros the fastest way out of this
pandemic
is for us to work together in solidarity
across sectors and across
borders vaccine nationalism will prolong
the pandemic
the pandemic has taken so much from us
but it has also given us something
the opportunity to think afresh
about the world we want we can build
the healthier safer and
fairer world we all
want and build back better
there it is you think it's any
coincidence that tedros is borrowing
biden's campaign slogan or who's
borrowing from whom these days
it's a signal that they're all on the
same team they all have the same
end goals individualism and individual
rights
will be subverted sublimated to the
global rights the communal rights
and it's a sign that joe biden won't put
america first he's
not out to make america better and he
won't
make that his first priority he's got to
do the bidding of bloomberg
wall street big business and the rest of
the special interest that bank rolled
his campaign
and of course that means kowtowing to
the elites who don't give a damn about
jobs and wages for americans
they never did that's why it's
imperative that we
hold the senate next year because with
the majority in that chamber
plus our gains in the house we actually
have a chance
at thwarting this kind of takeover of
the levers of power
from our government to a government far
far away
and we can make sure that the america
first movement continues to deliver
results
that our citizens and and we can use to
build a future where our children can
actually thrive
under the system of government and and
with our inalienable rights that we all
love and cherish and that's the angle